If you've ever used Google Maps, you may
have noticed that not only can you zoom
down to street level, but you can
also see what the location looks like
as if you were standing
there looking around.
This is called Street View.
It's an incredible, immersive technology
that allows you to explore the world
without leaving your desk.
If you think that's an exaggeration or
over marketing,
here's an example of street view
that actually happened to me.
As well as working for Google,
I've authored a number of very popular
young adult science fiction novels.
Two of the locations that I
have used in these novels
are the town of Shiprock in the Navajo
reservation in New Mexico, and
the town of Kawatana just
outside Nagasaki in Japan.
I've never been to either place,
but I've gotten fan
mail from people who live in them asking
me to say hi the next time I'm in town.
I did all of my location
research using Google Maps, and
in particular Google Street View.
The great news as an android developer,
is that all of this imagery is
available to you using Google's APIs.
Let's take a look at a simple
street View application
that allows you to
hike the Grand Canyon.